[Music]
welcome to the sit-down
I'm your host Patrick mid David in
today's episode we're gonna talk about
lessons and failure with four amazing
individuals if you were to change two or
three things for this to have lasted
what would those two or three things be
like um number one for sure would be the
delaying the gratification that's a
problem that a lot of young on us have
and I learned that the hard way is that
good things take time and there were
some moves I made that made me a lot of
money in the short term but then created
problems to be over the long term and
for example like Steve Madden shoes is
one of my companies right I remember
that was the majority shelter of Steve
Madden shoes if I had not had that
problem from all the stuff I did earlier
I would have made seven hundred million
a billion dollars even just over that
one you know versus making twenty thirty
million dollar gotta cuz I was forced to
sell it too early right that's one
example and there's so many other
examples just like that where first is
if I would have not gotten in trouble I
would have made the dot-com boom and
been positioned to have the biggest firm
out there during internet craze I
would've made billions off of that so
while I made a little bit of extra money
sooner it cost me a lot more with long
term by not playing that sort of long
game playing the short game and I think
that's a big mistake a lot of people
make and it's something I learned really
was crystallized when I wrote my first
book the wolf of Wall Street because
that took me a year to write I didn't
make anything while I was writing again
I mean I got some advance is very sure
right and then lo and behold over years
it turned into this amazing thing that
just spawned an entirely new life for me
so I think that it was a classic example
of something that we you work really
hard on something and it pays off down
the road so I think it's one major thing
is uh is that second thing is that I
think that a lot of young people it's
not because they're better it's not
about that because I was a really good
kid of a great family never got in
trouble you never got in trouble no no I
never we don't like it at all no never
got went to jail never I mean your dad
it from the way was pictured that was
trying to protect you a lot of counting
stuff
yeah often you think when you're younger
or when you're old if you haven't had
this this lesson taught you the hard way
is that I can be half pregnant when it
comes to ethics notice I could be
ethical but I could step over the line
downs and get away with it yeah the
problem with that is that when you step
over the ethical line once your line of
ethics moves a bit mmm so next time you
step over you'll step a bit further all
associated point further so so with me
you know I became desensitized to
essentially right and wrong behavior and
it's very easy on Wall Street we don't a
lot of people as you as we found out in
2007 it wasn't just me everyone Oh even
but 50 times bigger than where you live
now some of these guys cost a lot of
people my ways I you know I always say
everyone's doing it that's the old
excuse surely do it you should I did
what I did it was wrong yeah but the
point was it's very easy to point sable
everyone's doing it so you have to
that's such a good point you have to
maintain you at the gym really do this
no how do you do that very simple it
really is very simple you just don't
take the first step